[Music]
so it's not called
the king and this thing and the Bing and
the wing and the wing and the thing and
thinking whatever it's now called
the golden hour
which is good it's always good to keep
[ __ ] up your SEO and starting with a
new thing and it's also really great to
be called something that I'm going to
immediately call the golden shower
it's terrible right like it's golden
shower now
you made it way too easy
looked up in this Thomas right you know
yeah he's all
that was his last answer man yeah well
Joe can I be honest and I don't normally
compliment him
I kind of want that earthworm gym jacket
except he's wearing it so no I don't
yeah you can't have it because of the
anti-effects yeah you're a good point
Thomas Thomas wow
[Music]
patreon episode we got two of these a
month we are happy to have you here I
know how he picked the name
I know I picked the name because it's
the same Studio the the the [ __ ] LED
lighting in the stripe behind him that
was one of the settings was called
[Laughter]
oh my God he's right because he's he has
RGB no yes sir no Fergie's 100 right oh
my God they picked the name because the
stat the set was golden
I mean it beats spending money on you
know getting things refurnished bro
who's here oh we do get loose man
welcome to the golden hour not to be
confused with
golden shower right
they wait wait so yourself so you're
aware of this you're self-aware of your
piss name
exact your best name that's [ __ ]
weird apparently no you know what I bet
it was I bet [ __ ] Brandon came in and
was like we're gonna call it the golden
hour and Chris DeLeo is like that's
[ __ ] stupid
and Brendan was like oh yeah who else is
gonna have you on
am I wrong because I've got two chains
you mean to get you some change Two
Chains No oh you got that patreon money
let's get some change yeah
how many patrons is the golden hour have
the well you probably have to look up
the king and the wing and the sting bing
bong bing in the ding no they had to
have changed a name right
oh my God
oh my God
I found it
um I found it I found the patreon
um it's the golden hour and it says
select the membership at six dollars
which gives you two episodes and an ad
free version of regular episodes
and it's uh let me see it this year okay
okay first there were podcasts from one
person they were podcasts with two
people another part three people on a
podcast Theo Von Theo Von Brennan chop
and Crystal Lee are joining forces oh
theophon's out there anymore they
haven't updated that haven't updated
they only updated the name but they
didn't update the description so this
was and also hey
patrons are they're private I don't even
know how many they have I have no clue
because it's not a public a thing
oh okay yeah however many there's too
many
well I mean you could kind of get an
idea by looking at likes 36 likes 35
likes 66 likes 151 likes 129 likes 43
likes so
[Applause]
yeah well probably probably 600 if that
would be like it's going off the just
you know completely spiff on but I think
it's probably about around there
have uh you'd like be different with us
it kind of you you'd be like a it'd be
different yeah yeah tell him to come in
yeah yeah it would be like all right I
own a kiosk at the mall you know what I
mean yeah but not really your phone yeah
yeah yeah the entire time Brendan Circle
but I'm not talking but I'm not in his
head it's like I'm not talking why am I
not talk I should talk I should talk I
should talk right I should just always
have I should be talking yeah
so we have a problem with the families
like that's right yeah get ready for
Brandon do an impression
just resting so nicely within your chest
hair with that golden hour money though
you could move out of the apartment
where they're leaving trash all the time
yeah all the time what's that that new
thing he's doing I
don't know hey very weird
well we'll see about that he's doing
kind of like a a puker voice we'll see
how it goes let me let me let me get
it's been Chris baby let me get like
some episodes in before you just move
everything yeah yeah
we love it dude we love it and uh we're
all you know the set's looking good
we're gonna have some light behind here
so it's well here but you know we're
happy you're with us for the ride yeah
it looks like piss
it's like pass
oh I like this color yeah yeah she'll be
different for patreon baby
what other colors do we have we do it
right there change it right here right
you can change right now oh right now
right now it's gonna take two people
like maybe the patreon orange and
whatever you call it this is a good one
for the I like this is this the whole
show not only this is this is a this is
a best of clip but clip you know we do
little clips of our patreon episodes
this is their best of their this is the
best six minutes of the patreon episode
it's a little Charlie Brown sweatshirt
there that's okay that's okay it also
you know
patreon so we can piss on each other
well
what is it what
this is a patreon episode what do they
do they have no chemistry the patreon
episode we could piss on each other
it's like three guys wandered onto a set
that's what it is you're right it's like
they they wipe three strangers brains
and go do a podcast together enjoy and
I'll tell you exactly why too because
they probably have producers and stuff
that set everything up right yeah
they're there for like an hour whatever
and then like
they probably roll in like I guarantee
like one of them's always late or like
you know what I mean they're always like
sitting around so there's usually
probably never like a pre thing like
where you're sitting down doing the show
and you're you guys are getting ready
and then like you start getting a Vibe
and then you go live
like these guys are just like I
guarantee they're all just kind of
sitting around on their phones right
just like not talking and then like the
producer's setting up and then they wait
for like crystallia to show up like you
know 15 minutes late and be like oh
sorry guys and then they just all right
let's go come on let's go I gotta get to
go do a spot in an hour
so it's like they just flipped the mics
on and it's like yeah so so you're like
you guys haven't been around to each
other all day it's weird
it's a little Charlie Brown sweatshirt
there that's okay that's okay it also
you know
patreon so we can piss on each other
well no wow so
hey bro are you about this life or not
yeah I have a problem with that your set
costs seven hundred dollars
because you know California is probably
more expensive but I'm just you know
if we're not talking if we're excluding
the mics I'm not cutting microphones or
other equipment I'm talking about the
set I'm talking about the table and the
lights behind them those lights behind
you get on Amazon I know exactly which
ones they are the little switch you can
change the colors and then you can make
an X the golden hour thing you got made
of the [ __ ] print shop probably cost
you about a couple hundred bucks that
desk is your typical podcasting decks
yes this print shop guys on retainer he
has so many [ __ ] signs for so many
tips good point yeah Lady Lady Brendan's
putting putting my kids through college
[Laughter]
is that oh the Green's nice
um yeah it's so [ __ ] set you could
have put together in a Spencer's Gifts
I think you're in there too
[ __ ] what's the difference they're
both filled with dicks
yeah let's get the can I get this
[ __ ] stoned staff from with Spencer's
Gifts in that studio thank you instead
thank you for March Madness oh for my
birthday what do you guys doing for
March Madness
um wait actually do you have holiday
plans yet intern over there we're
[ __ ] with the lights
bro this is the best sick Mannix look
bro I'll put up our polar bear segment
clip yeah this is a six minute clip this
is there this is stairs this is on their
official thing this is the best six
minutes that this this is the video
they're using to sell you to join your
patreon
what do you do I have kids so what do
you do is that the house yeah and then
everyone comes over to your house yeah
who like extended Tim pointed out the
shitty creases and they're [ __ ] their
room dividers oh look look look yeah
look at the lines that's not even a real
wall behind that's is that a cardboard
oh we dude our theory is correct
is that hold on let me full screen is
that cardboard look at the corners dude
our Theory I think is correct
I think that they really are in a little
weird like cam girl type stuff yeah
that's [ __ ] cheap that's hilarious
oh dude they those are the same mics for
every set too I bet yeah of course
they move it's just cardboard they move
the background and they unplug it
because it has the lights on it the same
desk that they use for all the shows I
mean maybe I don't really know probably
paying attention yeah friends and [ __ ]
oh my dad comes after okay so but my
girl's family would be there oh okay
cool gotcha because they all live here
right right where are you going I don't
know I think I want to go on a trip I
like going like tropical oh that's nice
I don't like that I don't like that well
I I wouldn't want to eat snow what is
this
Christmas you need snow
this is where's is there anything funny
this is like you said three guys just
wander on a set and then this is the
clip this is literally the warm-up and
they're just cut it out like it's fine
oh disguise did and then she was being
so mean you know what I mean nice like
you're sick and she's being mean like
that's great I feel like I'm dying and
then she's ordering room service oh you
know yeah just the smells like vomiting
stop vomiting yeah I want the shrimp
yeah it was like Eric can you stop
cheating your pants for one second he
just copies him look do you see that he
even as the hand thing you don't even
have to do that I mean yeah you were
found the same kind of thing but but you
look at it look watch you just copies
him put the shrimp yeah it was like Eric
can you stop cheating your pants for one
second she was like this smell this is
crazy and I was like and then just the
way she was acting I was like I can't be
with somebody that's gonna act like this
then what happened
yeah it worked out man it worked out
five years later from now never forget
that never forget though you know so now
lest we forget though
what
what
all three of these guys are comedians
can I be honest yeah if these three guys
were having this conversation off the
air I would walk away
like even if it wasn't a show I just
walked away from him right now I think
I'm done with it I can't I just walked
away from here you know I mean unless
she hasn't unless there's some
is there that's just an objection I'm
moving on because I mean
um wow they're just
they just want to get that money and go
huh they don't even want to I believe
they were quoted as saying is give me
the loop give me the loop give me the
loot
dude don't get me wrong like not every
show we do is a [ __ ] Grand Slam but
this one was
this one was pretty good but I mean
we're not that boring it's like you know
what I mean imagine if we just came in
and we're like Yeah man so like
Christmas like what do you do for
Christmas
this is cool cool
anyway
are you Chris oh I rape hey hey guys did
you notice the name of our show is like
getting peed on
we probably should have done that